لان جاءت هبه التضامن الانساني كعادتها في
الكوارث والفواجع عابره للحدود والعراق
والاديان فان حمله الاغاثه في هذا الزلزال
لم تكن كذلك انها باتجاه مناطق الشمال
السوري المنكوبه تبدو معطله تماما رغم مضي
اربعه ايام على الانهيار الكبير وما يعنيه
ذلك من ضياع اوقات ثمينه وحاسمه كفيله
بانتشال مئات الاحياء من تحت الانقاض
[موسيقى]
هذه اول قافله مساعدات تجتاز معبر باب
الهوى الحدودي بين تركيا وسوريا منذ زلزال
فجر الاثنين الماضي لكن قافله الامم
المتحده المكونه من ست شاحنات حملت اغذيه
واغطيه وخيما لا معدات اغاثه وفرق بحث
وانقاذ واطقم طبيه وتلك اولويه السوريين
الان وان اوشك الوقت على النفاذ حيث تؤكد
فرق الانقاذ هناك تسارع معدل وفاه
العالقين تحت الانقاض وان كل ساعه تاخير
تقابلها 50 وفاه
الدفاع المدني في تلك المناطق غير الخاضعه
لسيطره النظام السوري قال ان قافله
المساعدات هذه دوريه وليس الطارئه بل هي
حصه متاخره اصلا تم تعليقها بسبب الزلزال
فضلا عن انها لا تلبي سوى احتياجات نحو
خمسه الاف شخص في منطقه تضم اكثر من اربعه
ملايين نازح ومشرد غياب الاستجابه الدوليه
لماساه الزلزال في شقها السوري تعزوها
الامم المتحده الى عده عوائق واولها قرار
مجلس الامن الدولي الذي يحصر نقل
المساعدات بمعبر باب الهوى ناوي
حان الوقت لاستكشاف جميع السبل الممكنه
لايصال المساعدات والفرق الى جميع المناطق
المتضرره يجب ان تكون اولويتنا مساعده
المتضررين ثانيا يجب توفير خارج الاساسيه
الصندوق الانساني السوري والصندوق
المساعدات الانسانيه العابر للحدود بحاجه
الى دعم عاجل دعوه مرهونه بالوقت وفي
انتظار ما سيحدث ربما بعد فوات الاوان
تتدفق على باب الهواء مزيد من الجثانين
للاجئين سوريين قضوا في الزلزال داخل
تركيا
باتجاه المثوى الاخير في بلادهم
[موسيقى]